welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar optimization
study of supercritical fluid extraction
of cannabinoids from cannabis sativa
presented by Erik Kafka founder of khat
is scientific
my name is Xavier Gutierrez and I will
be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars now before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation and if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem and this
presentation is educational and those
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming Eric Kafka I will
now turn the presentation over to him
hello my name is Eric Kafka I'm the
founder of can of scientific were a R&D
laboratory in the Hardwick Vermont
Hardwick is the the northeast corner of
Vermont almost on the border of Canada
and we focus our efforts on exploring
SFX technology and how that relates to
candidates and I see SFX I'm referring
to SF e supercritical fluid extraction
on the front end and also both prepara
Dave's and analytical SFC supercritical
fluid chromatography on the on the back
on the back end and so today we have two
slides outlining some optimization work
that we've been doing using
supercritical fluid extraction
techniques targeting cannabinoids from
industrial hemp
and so before we get into the slides
let's appreciate the complexity of
candidates and with cannabis we're
really interested in two classes of
compounds one class are terpenoids
and terpenoids are the natural aroma and
flavor molecules of P Animists and in
nature there's we've identified around
3000 different terpenes all these 3000
terpenes the cannabis plant makes or we
have identified all these 3,200 within
cannabis another class of compounds that
were really interested in our
cannabinoids THC CBD CBG there's 80 plus
cannabinoids that we have identified in
cannabis and of course a lot of
cannabinoids are minor cannabinoids and
the two classes of compounds
cannabinoids and terpenoids
together give us his entourage effect
and Ethan Rousseau best describes our
entourage effect where he says you know
the idea of 2+2 instead of that equaling
Spore it'll yield 8 in medicinal value
and so these terpenoids and cannabinoids
they interact with in our
endocannabinoid system and within our
endocannabinoid system we have around
300 different receptors and each
receptor can accept the multiple
terpenoids
and multiple cannabinoids and so if we
were to to ask the question how does
cannabis work well that's a really
complex question right um and we really
can't take a model pharmaceutical
approach that question of course Marlo's
pharmaceutical of being one compound for
one condition and stem you take a poly a
poly for the simple approach where we
have multiple components interacting
together and so cod to recap really
quick there's two hundred-plus
terpenoids 100 plus cannabinoids
interacting on 300 different receptors
where each receptor to accept the
multiple cannabinoids and multiple
terpenoids
so as you can imagine to answer a simple
question how to scan in this work well
happy that works that becomes a very
complex problems installed and so here
we have what I like to call by
California Cruiser in this slide it's a
work in progress and it's their attempt
to explain the relationship between
terpenes and cannabinoids and the way I
like to explain it is is a bicycle and
in a bike has two wheels a front wheel
and a back wheel and we know that the
back wheel the bike provides the the
energy to propel that bike forward while
the front wheel kind of steers the bike
and now what I like to do is imagine the
back wheel being a cannabinoids in
cannabis propelling fueling that
euphoric psycho activity while the front
wheel are terpenoids kind of altering
the direction of how we're gonna feel
from that particular strain of cannabis
right and so basically you know on one
side indica was more sedate of type
properties on the other side sativa once
again it's still a work in progress but
we'll just leave that there
so today we have a few slides we'll
start by reviewing some prior work done
on extracting cannabinoids from cannabis
use icing supercritical fluid extraction
then we'll extend the boundaries of
cannabinoid extraction using utilizing
co2 by looking at the mass transfer
property of of co2 and of course mass
transfer being the slow rate of co2 and
then we'll have a quick slide on future
optimization optimization work that we
can do so if you were to google
supercritical fluid extraction and
natural products and you'll probably get
a thousand plus different hits on Google
and this is one example a publication
from 2011 where this group explored
extracting sugar cane and clothes
utilizing sfv and they built these a
overall abstraction curves where on the
x axis we have time
on the y-axis we have percent of our COI
compound of interest and their goal was
to develop these overall extraction
curves and from that Deena develop
strategy to scale from 250 ml a 250 ml
vessel to a 5 liter vessel and they were
able to do this by maintaining their
solvent to speed ratio s over s and and
we'll talk more about that in the later
slides and if you were to refine your
Google search and if you're to search s
Fe and cannabinoids well from a thousand
hits we get a very limited number of
publications and this is one of the
first publications that came out in 2010
where this group looked at the
solubility of of cannabinoids in
supercritical co2 and of course
solubility data is super important if we
know the relative solubility of terpenes
and co2 and relatively relatives
solubility of Kannapolis in co2 well
then we could effectively remove these
two classes of compounds from each other
and within the class of terpenoids once
again if we know that solubility data of
terpenes within the class of
monoterpenes and suspect our beans well
by utilizing sfv were able to separate
our monoterpenes out from our suspect
ravines also on the kinetic side with
the proper solubility data we're able to
separate our acidic cannabinoids from
our neutral cannabinoids and so from
this work we know that CBD is way more
soluble in co2 than CBD a CBD a is more
soluble than TCA and also THC is more
soluble than THC a another publication
that you'll find online is from 2017
where this group investigated extraction
of s Fe but in looking at different coke
solvents and different strategies of
introducing that cone solvent into the
extraction chamber
and so they looked at two strategies one
it's a constant flow of ethanol meaning
that there's just throughout the life of
the extraction there they're flowing in
a constant X ml of ethanol and the
second strategy was a pulse
strategy of ethanol where they will cost
X amount of ethanol at different various
stages of the of the extraction and what
they concluded is a pulse strategy is
more effective than a constant flow and
with that with the pulse flow strategy
they were obtaining extraction
efficiencies of 92 percent and higher
and so terpenoids and cannabinoids are
synthesized and stored within the
tri-coat and the trichome is is granular
hairlike structure as pictured here and
depending how we separate or concentrate
that trichome well that will dictate
what kind of product me baby right and
so kind of two you know two different
approaches we can make ice water hash
where we're just knocking off that
trichome and and sifting it through to
make a concentrated product or we can
selectively extract that trichome
utilizing co2 and both will yield
different products in terms of co2 and
utilising sfe the way we prepare the
material will dictate how well how
efficient our extraction will be and
we'll see a little bit more on that on
the next slide and so here we have a
inefficient efficiency curve a co2
efficiency curves and so if you ever
dress out your extraction where we have
time on the x actions and grams of co y
compound of interest in this example
it's CBD from hemp on the y axis you'll
see a graph that looks something like
this and there's two evident regions
within this curve that we'll see and the
first region
i like to call them account
region and then the second regions the
the diffusion limited region and so
within the mechanical region
Stokes that have experienced utilizing
SME you know using sfe for extraction
you'll notice that within the first 16
minutes you get a rush of material right
and so why does that happen
well it goes back to how you prepared
that material and so firstly probably
ground that material and when we grind
cannabis right we're knocking off those
trichomes and during our mechanical
region of extraction those trichomes are
liberated from the flour and they're
available for the co2 to basically pick
it up and transport it into our
extraction vessel right after the
mechanical region the extraction gets a
little bit tougher and we enter the
diffusion limited region where
solubility really has to happen the co2
has to come in has to cleave that
trichome and then once it Cleaves a
trichome it's able to transport that try
the contents of that trichome from the
flour into our collection chamber and so
the mechanical region happens pretty
fast the diffusion limited region is
kind of painful region of extraction and
so this works we're looking at how can
we make the diffusion limited region
less painful how could we expedite that
process in SFTP so we have three three
parameters that we can control utilizing
co2 and the first two parameters are
thermodynamic properties pressure and
temperature and at each a specific
temperature and a specific pressure we
could calculate a density and based off
that density number typically the higher
the density the more aggressive co2 will
be and lower that number the less
aggressive co2 will be in terms of
extraction and the third property is
mask
and for a flow rate and typically one
would think the higher the flow rate
well the the higher our rate of
extraction is the lower the slow rate
well the lower our rate of extraction
would be and I have question marks on
the grass here and the reason being is I
do believe that that is true when we're
speaking terms of the mechanical region
of this crash occurs and so the more co2
we flow through the mechanical region
the faster that will extract that region
however when we enter the diffusion
limited region of the extraction curve
I'm not convinced that a higher flow
rate means a faster extraction and we'll
see why in the in the slides to come so
a lot of times I like to pick explain
something complicated like extracting
cannabinoids from cannabis and and
explain that in terms of something that
we do every day and for me it's brewing
a cup of coffee and so kind of looking
at the workflow of brewing coffee right
and you know first it starts with
selecting the right bean and of course
we know that a coffee bean from Costa
Rica is completely different in flavor
than see a coffee bean from from
Colombia so next week we locate our
being and then we grind that beam right
to to make more surface area and then if
we're brewing some French press coffee
we load into our extraction chamber we
filled that extraction chamber with our
solvent in this case it's hot water and
we let that soak say we let that soak
for four minutes
and while our coffee is soaking in the
water we're effectively extracting our
our compounds of interest that may be
the essential oils or caffeine right
we're extracting without slow we're
letting solubility occur after four
minutes we plunge that coffee and we
harvest our extract with
and we pour into our cup into a coffee
cup and we effective effectively have a
cup of coffee now if we were to analyze
this the first round we do this say we
extract 10% of the available available
caffeine I'm just making 10% up for this
example well you can imagine that we do
this around again right so we take the
the extracted coffee from round one we
put it back into our French press
extraction vessel we fill water again
we extract without flow we're letting
solubility happen we plunged the coffee
we poured out into a cup into our cup
and then after the second round
maybe we extract an additional 5% of
caffeine and we can keep doing this over
and over again until we we effectively
removes say 70% of the available
caffeine so that's one strategy of
brewing coffee the other strategy is
what let's pack this coffee into a into
a column and it's blast water through it
really quick say at a hundred litres per
minute right and after one minute we
probably won't extract a lot of caffeine
reason being if we're flowing that water
at a really high flow well we're not
allowing solubility to occur right
there's no no time for the water to
interact with the coffee and so that'll
be not as an effective method as the
first strategy where were allowing water
to soak with the coffee and anamur
harvesting after soaking and so this is
the approach we're gonna take with with
extracting candidates and I call a
static dynamic approach to boost
efficiency in the diffusion limited
region of the extraction the efficiency
Kurt and we'll see how that plays out in
in the next slide or tube and so some of
the instrumentation used for this work
the waters biomechanical extractor a
great a piece of equipment for this
works we have
control that each each point we were
able to control our flow rate were able
to control the temperature at each zone
and also we're able to control our
pressure and on the analytical side
we're using a Judy UPC squared so this
is our experimental setup we're so in
Vermont we have a very limited medical
marijuana program however hemp is pretty
open and so our laboratory does all our
work on an industrial hemp and so for
this work we've acquired 25 pounds of
high CBD hemp we homogenized all 25
pounds and then we tested it to get 13.4
13.5 percent CBD a and we're running
three different trials trial one were
extracting at 250 bar at 50 C and this
is a dynamic run so basically we're
flowing at 200 grams per minute for 550
minutes
conditions set number two were
extracting at 250 bar at 50 C and now
we're taking a dynamic static approach
we're extracting for 60 minutes and then
we're soaking for 15 minutes we're
extracting for 16 minutes soaking for 50
minutes and we keep doing this on and
off for a total of five hundred five
hundred fifty minutes so we're keeping
the time constant here that's trial
number one and then trial number three
we're extracting once again at two
hundred fifty bar 50 C and we're also
taking a static dynamic approach but now
we're keeping our solvent to speed ratio
constant SS trial one and when I say
something to feed I mean the ratio of
grams of solvent used over grams of
starting material and that ratio is
constant as trial 1 and so let's look at
some data Oh
so first is looking at the the program
of how the difference between
ambach and dynamic static it's on the
top really simple we're just flowing at
200 grams per minute and we're
extracting at 250 bar 500 for 500 15
minutes and then in the dynamic static
approach were altering our flow rate
between 200 grams per minute and 5 grams
per minute so what are extracting at 200
grams per minute that's the dynamic leg
of the run and then when we reduce our
float of 5 grams per minute we're
calling that a static soak yes we're
flowing some co2 by a 5 breaths per
minute it's essentially just soaking
there and then all the way to the right
you can see we're extracting at 250 bar
and we're alternating 16 minutes at
flowing at 200 and then we're reducing
that for 15 minutes at 500 and we keep
doing that and so here's some data and
so in trial number one and this is the
dynamic run we've calculated the total
potential CPD and when I say total
potential I'm referring to 0.87 seven
times cbda plus the CBD number and in
trial 1 we have a total potential 215
grams we're extracting for five hundred
forty minutes and we at the end of the
extraction we harvested a hundred forty
eight grams and so that gives us an
extraction efficiency of 69% and some
other parameters that were looking at
here is how many grams of co2 we we used
we're looking at the s2f ratio
once again the grams of co2 over grams
of starting material and then the next
column we're looking at how many grams
of co2 need to be used per gram
extracted gram of CBD right and that's
an important metric which tells us how
efficient are we using our co2 so trial
number two where we took a dynamic
static approach
where we're holding the time constant as
number one and so once again in the
starting material we've calculated that
we had 223 grams of total potential CBD
since we're keeping our time constant
we're extracting for 540 minutes we
harvested 124 grams of total CBD which
gives us a ratio or extraction
efficiency of 56 percent and so after
trial 1 the initial thought was we're
not moving in the right direction of
this optimization work and this
experiment is not working right 56 is
definitely lower than 69 percent but
then when you look at the gram of co2
per gram of CBD ratio we went from 731
in trial 1 to 608 on trial
- and so what that's telling us is well
we're we're using our field to more
efficiently meaning we're pulling out
more CBD for a gram of co2 so two
conclusions one we're not fully
optimized here however we are moving in
the right direction
right it's all quickly looking at trial
3 where now we took the same approach
static dynamic approach but now we're
keeping our solvent to feed ratio
constant right so effectively we're
using more co2 so we've calculated that
we use two hundred sixteen grams or we
had available to us two hundred sixteen
grams of CBD available now we're
extracting for six hundred fifteen
minutes reason being were soaking for 15
minutes after every dynamic run were
soaking for 15 minutes so that's
accruing some time but in trial 3 we
harvested 191 grams of CBD giving us an
expression efficiency of 88% and looking
and so looking at the other parameters
we've maintained our solvent to feed
ratio of 50
nine which is great and we are grams of
co2 per gram of CBD is down to 572 once
again meaning where now we're even more
effectively using one gram of co2 to
pull out even more CBD which is great
and so now our optimization work is
moving in the right direction we've
boosted our efficiency from 69% to 88%
one little drawback here is our
extraction time went from 540 minutes to
650 minutes so our overall extraction is
a little bit longer but in in in a slide
coming will present a situation where
we're able to maintain our 80%
extraction to sufficiency but also
maintain our fibers 40-minute extraction
so here we're looking at the rafen II so
trial 1 is going from left to right on
the diagram one is from the dynamic run
and 3 is from the dynamic static where
we kept our ratio constant and we're
we're looking at we're trying to gather
some channeling data and basically
where's our CBD caught up in our
extraction and so if you imagine a
extraction chamber we we take a sample
from the bottom from the middle and from
the top and in the dynamic run we've
calculated that we we're leaving behind
2.73 percent of CBD are we on the top of
the vessel and on the bottom of the
vessel we're leaving behind one point
three one point zero three one percent
of CBD in trial to where the the
conditions were not optimized we left
behind four percent CBD and 0.8 percent
on on the bottom of the vessel and this
was another indication where we were
moving in the right direction with our
optimization right on comparing you know
one to two
trial 1 we an owns a percent of CBD on
the bottom in trial 2 where we're not
fully optimized we only had 0.8% CBD so
that once again was telling us that
we're using our our co2 more effectively
and then trial 3 where we were fully
optimized we left behind a percent on
the top 0.6%
on the bottom and that averages out to
overall around 0.84% left behind in the
raffinate and so here are some
chromatograms it want to be a
presentation without looking at
chromatograms and so this is the the
raffinate and on the top we have the
dynamic run where receive some of cynics
nama drugs left behind in the middle we
have the dynamic static trial where we
kept the time constant and we have some
neutral cannabinoids showing up in there
and that's telling us that yeah we
didn't pull out all the material even
our neutral calamities are left behind
it or a phonate and then down below
where we kept our salt in the feed
racial constant we have will CBD but
noted are below the limit of detection
on the THC so the balance the fully
optimized run as looking at some
extraction economics we run ahead and
calculated how many grams of total
potential CBD are we leaving behind in
the raffinate and so in the dynamic run
we left behind around sixty seven grams
of CBD and the dynamic static run we
left behind where we kept the time
constant we left behind 99 grams of CBD
once again that was not fully optimized
and then in the trial where we kept the
the salt and the feed ratio constant
we're leaving behind 25 grams of CBD now
in our lab were defining 90% extractions
extraction efficiency acceptable and so
if we're if we're normalizing all this
to 90% extraction efficiency and we're
assigning
a dollar value to uh how much grams of
co2 of CBD we're leaving behind in
Vermont full-spectrum CBD runs be like
around $35 a gram and so on the dynamic
run we're leaving behind approximately
$1,500 $1,500 we're losing per run and
so if we extrapolated this you know for
per week where we did two extractions
per per day so ten liters a day and
we're leaving behind $1,500 each
extraction well that's almost fifteen
thousand dollars a week that were losing
in in CBD so if we left our optimization
work right here right even though if you
recall we are extending a little time
we're adding an additional 110 minutes
to our extraction however it's still
worth it right now we're saving fifteen
hundred dollars or fifteen thousand
dollars per week but we went ahead and
we further optimized this that we'll see
in in the next slide right here and so
the next step was you know previously we
were just extracting for 60 minutes
soaking for 15 and those two numbers 60
and 15 we just kind of came up randomly
and so next we wanted to see well if 60
and 15 the right number so 60 the right
number to extract dynamically is 15 the
right number to to soak and so for a few
abstractions we we tracked the
extraction by collecting a sample every
15 minutes and after 60 minutes we we
let that soak for 15 minutes and then
during the dynamic run we collected once
again samples every 15 minutes and if we
looked at the the upper curve at plot B
where we're looking at grams of it's a
rate grams of CBD over time we could
immediately identify where our
mechanical region of the extraction
curve happens and that is
within the first in this case within the
first 60 minutes we're just you know
we're cranking at 12 grams of CBD per
minute and so that's a mechanical region
of the curve and then the extraction
dies down to the diffusion limited reads
it and so our next strategy was
identifying okay how long let's identify
how long the mechanical region lasts and
after that mechanical region let's start
soaking after that and so we're from
this graph we're seeing that our
extraction efficiency kind of levels out
after a hundred five minutes and then
after one hundred five minutes
we'll start soaking for 15 and then
extraction for 16 so we're trying to do
is save up our extract our soak tokens
and apply them to the back end of the
extraction where where we really need
them during the diffusion limited region
of the curves and so now our our program
looks something like this where we're
dine and aleix tracting for a hundred
five minutes at 200 grams per minute and
then after a hundred five minutes we
reduce our float down to five grams per
minute and now we're starting our soak
for 15 minutes and we're going on and
off 15 60 15 60 and so by saving our
quote unquote you know soap tokens for
later an extraction with this method we
we are consistently obtaining extraction
efficiencies well you know 90 percent in
the bugs and once again we're still
maintaining our solvent the feed ratio
of 59
however we were so our efficiency went
up a little bit more but we're still
extracting for six hundred fifteen
minutes and so the next slide right here
as well how can we maintain our 90
percent extraction efficiency but
complete the extraction in five hundred
forty minutes and so this method becomes
we optimized whenever using two five
leader vessels and so you can imagine a
scenario where we have to extraction
vessels were extracting extraction
vessel number one while they were
soaking traction vessel number two and
so after extracting vessel one for sixty
minutes we switch and so now vessel one
is soaking while we're extracting vessel
number two and we keep switching that we
keep doing this for five hundred forty
minutes so now effectively we're not
losing that 15 minutes of soap time
we're just confuse me continuously
extracting but now we're altering the
flow to different extraction vessels and
now this tactic we're able to maintain
our ninety percent extraction efficiency
but also maintain our 540 min extraction
time as overall we're witnessing a 30
percent boost in efficiency with the
static dynamic approach when we apply
that to the diffusion limited region of
the of the extraction church I like to
thank in the oven from Water Corporation
Sean he'll Mueller from Deutsche process
dr. John McKay from synergistic tech
Associates for for collaborating and
bouncing ideas and also lab routes for
putting this great event together and of
course everybody that tuned in and it's
listening to this presentation that's my
story I'm sticking to it thank you very
much well thank you Eric for your
informative presentation I would also
like to thank libraries for making
today's educational webcast possible and
as a final reminder our speaker will
follow up with any questions you've
submitted via email that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye